but yeah today will be more about
end-to-end data prevalence code and
presented it already where we think
about using git as a nosql database um
and this talk will be about that but
also about more of the implication of it
like how we got it to that stage to our
v1 and then our v2 and um yeah today we
just wanna dive into that a bit it's
gonna be more like you guys hands on
trying it out as well so if you have
your laptop feel free to pull it out and
then we can we'll walk you through some
of the
oh
yeah some of some of the things that we
have done there um and then you can try
it out as well
but just to get things started and who
this person is here so basically yeah
it's hang the founder ceo who's sitting
there and me batting i'm doing the
customer success team here in the us
um and yeah today we'll just talk a bit
about that so if you have any questions
feel free to just like shout it or or
reach out um
but essentially i think i want to start
things off with like figuring out who's
in the room i mean usually we talk to
engineers a lot but there may be
founders maybe analytics engineers maybe
other people
and for that i actually did prepare
a slido thing and let me actually pull
that up really quickly
um everybody just wants to
quickly
join on slido it's a slightly comment
and you can just use this number and
then for this out this would be great
just for me to
get kind of an understanding of who's in
this room
okay we got
a lot of other
maybe we should have added another
option then
that's good to know
okay nice um
closes in just a second
okay everybody's other does anybody want
to share what other means to them
who put who put others that's what you
want to do
data governance okay interesting
what are the other others in here
for this person
okay
it's good to know well maybe we should
have extended our choices of video maybe
it's a biased but good good to know that
it's others um the next question is
maybe also a bit biased but it's
interesting to see i mean we obviously
have one bet here but for us um
there's this kind of point i just want
to see like what people are thinking in
this room um the question is do you
believe that all in one data platforms
can keep up with their promise um it's a
bit of a double negative but yeah
yeah
to be fair okay yeah maybe i should have
phrased it more directly
so that no means you believe in keeping
up their promises okay
yeah yeah yeah so you believe in failure
um
okay oh it's a 50 50 split not bad not
bad um last part which is what do you
like to learn this workshop um this is a
free form answer i believe everything is
set up correctly
does that work maybe not i'm not sure
does it show up anything
oh yeah
space kids
skating performance
nice
something new that's always good
great i think i'll
close it here
um
yeah so basically and the reason i asked
this is actually uh there's ways to to
do this workshop and i want to make sure
it's also tailored to what like you
actually want to get out of it it's
going to probably maybe also just be a
session where we talk about things and
not too many things that we present but
going back to
the presentation it's here
what i want to do today is essentially
just walk you through a use case that we
see quite often so you can get to see
how the platform works for that use case
in both ends one the
one that hung presented where it's more
about just enabling the business user to
use the entire modern data stack in one
tool and then the second part is as you
can see here the programmable data
pipeline as code
and we want to do this at the example of
raycon which is one of our customers
actually i don't know have you heard of
raycon before it's like an earbuds
company e-commerce d2c and essentially
their setup is they have a bunch of
google sheets where they have all their
ads data in there um they pull it
manually sometimes maybe they use funnel
before that and then
later on they actually use python so
their analytics person
just wrote some code to to make sure to
get the data together transform it and
then they push it into data studio
basically there they just pick it up and
use it
and that was their setup and they
weren't actually
happy with it at all
and they were quite small so it's one
analytics person
not a massive engineering team that was
able to do everything on their own and
they were looking at basically
simplifying the entire process to get
the head of marketing
happy and then make sure that everything
works out so at this example i want to
first look at how
y42 can empower business users to become
data experts and then really the second
part where going away from the business
user and more actually to the data and
like expert figuring out how the
platform is trying to solve both ends
and doing so as well
um so the first part is here empowering
business users to become data experts
and
there are three parts that we wanted to
achieve with this product which is one
simplify the modern data stack so this
is making sure that you don't have to
actually set up seven plus tools which
makes sense i think sometimes but
sometimes for a single analytics person
it can be quite a lot um the second part
is shortest time to value so figuring
out how they can actually get up an
entire data pipeline within maybe a
couple of minutes and then the last part
is the full pipeline transparency
um to do that i actually would want to
give you access to the platform and we
can kind of do it like a walkthrough
where you can try out some of the parts
of the platform and to do that
you have to visit this is also quite
bad and i think it would have to be many
on the laptops if you have a laptop that
works if not
no worries at all
it's y42.com
data console
and when you do this i'm going to pull
this up actually right now as well
you will be
forwarded
to
this page and this is basically our free
trial page where you can get access to a
platform 14 days so you can try it out
afterwards as well um just put your name
and your email and then you'll actually
receive an email to activate your
account and you can try out the platform
there
and otherwise i will also just share how
it would look like on our end
i'm just going to give you guys a couple
of minutes go back to the url as well
i'm sorry it's just
a bit harder here
spend a lot of time looking for space
cats
i'm gonna pull it up at the same time
so i'm actually gonna
change
okay so
once you have activated did you guys
get to get the email already
nothing
yet
were you able able to fill out the form
did that work at least
maybe you have to check your spam
because i think sometimes oh is that
yeah okay i think you have to check out
your spam that maybe we need to work on
our deliverability um
but once you
have that it should send you to a lane
to activate it
so uh we got to fix that i'm we're not
going to take your data maybe we're
going to take your data um but no this
is uh it's just
i think it should be fine to activate it
the others were you guys able to
get an email activate things the ones
that are looking at this
i'll also log in and then walk you
through what we want to do today
so yeah once you activate just have to
sign in again
and then it will take a couple of
minutes and actually load demo data into
your account um that you can then today
work with as well and also a bit um but
you can also actually integrate some of
your data so this is actually hosted on
our bigquery so usually when you set up
y42 you could choose to do bigquery
snowflake
as your background data warehouse in
this case with the free trial you would
get basically the access to all bigquery
and store data on there as well so if
you do any of your data feel free to
delete it we will make sure that
everything is deleted after this as well
but you can go ahead and do that as well
are you guys the people who are
following along locked in already no
okay actually i can maybe
so who was able to get in you got in is
it
oh okay
did anybody else get access to it
already is anybody in
okay you are in okay
i mean we can also just follow along
through the screen
yeah we could do that as well um
let's see let me just generate one
really quickly
actually do you have
i'll actually invite you all to the same
organization then you can just play
around there as well um
that's
right right let's call it
is
anybody else's
involved as um
that just applies to the same
organization and there you
can then use the same stuff that we have
here
did you guys receive the email yet
to get invited
to the land of the spam again maybe
hurries
oh
yeah we can do that as well so
actually
i'm gonna set the password
okay i will just set an account and then
give everybody access as well
okay
so i will write it up here
so
if you would like to
um if you'd like to log in you can
actually log in with i will
pull up
if you go to y42.com
um
like this one here
i believe
yeah if you go to edward.y42.com
in here and then you can
just click in
click here and then just insert
mateentron plus sorry dot trend plus
free trial three at y42.com and the
password is data console 2022
exclamation mark then you should be able
to log in
did you get access already through
different means okay
so it's
app.y42.com
and then in here it's just parting.tran
at
sorry plus free trial 3
and y42.com
and password is
data console 2022 exclamation mark
did that work for people
cool okay so yeah once you're in there
um you will be able to see a whole bunch
of organizations and you can go on to
data console for now
[Music]
in there here you should be able to
oh i think i need to change
just the user settings
i'm gonna assign
yeah and here you should be able to see
the integrations one-on-ones i just set
you as an um manager
got it
so when you click on integrate now do
you see these three
data sources
cool so yeah the first thing that i want
to just go through is
editing integration and as you can see
here
if you follow along you can just see the
whole bunch of integrations and you can
try out a google sheet if you want want
to add words obviously then like don't
choose any of the data that is maybe
visible um through other means but in
this case
you can then just for example see
a whole bunch of things so i'll test
this
google analytics and in this case for
example you would just have to
sign in with your email i'll use my
personal one because i have a throwaway
alexa copy there basically
if you want to integrate you can go
ahead and just
wait for a second and then it will show
up there as well
zoom out
give it some seconds
um and then the other way you can
already look at the existing data for
example here in the facebook one there's
preloaded data and there you can find
that
do you guys see the the data set are
those there cool yeah and in here for
example this is a window into the data
that you get when you integrate y42 it's
a google sheets like so you would just
um basically get a window into there you
can see
descriptive stats and so on so all that
is accessible there as well
you can see summarization so this is how
hawaii 42 basically works for a business
user you can see general stats and the
way you integrate and actually select
tables here is
for example i would select my account
and
then i can go ahead and select tables
that are in that account for google
analytics
and there are a whole bunch of other
integrations that we use right now but
with the new app that hong will show
also in the second half of this um
you'll get actually access to um five
trillion airbyte and so on as well where
you can pull those into your
orchestration um and then trigger out of
our airflow basically sorry trigger out
of oil orchestration or trigger any
other airflow runs
so here for example this is where you
can get all the data
and you can select the columns that are
involved there
so this is how that would work but for
today's use case if we think back to
what raycon did they wanted to combine
google ads and facebook ads
we can go in and see there's these two
data sets
that are already in here they have a
whole bunch of data in there maybe they
have spend they have the campaign id the
cost and so on the next part in this
whole journey would be to actually
create a model that unifies this data
and there is one existing in here
already
that if you
check out on in the model tab you can
see how you have the ui model which is
the part where y42 basically allows a
business user to
create
sql transformations without knowing sql
without having to know sql
and if you want to you can go ahead and
just create a model yourself by clicking
on the add button here either sql in ui
and then we can
follow along
is that working for you if you click on
the add button and create a model
great here you can then
see all the notes on the left and for
example the first one would be to input
a data set so you would basically just
pull in
one of the input nodes
you click on them and then you can
select all the data sources and tables
basically that you've created before
and in here we would for example select
the google ads data from the ad
performance report
you get an
output overview so this is a preview of
everything that's in there and then you
can check it out as long as you
basically just stay in this window and
if you save it
it stays as the input here
and then we have a whole bunch of
transformations and then for this use
case for example we can
just select
maybe the cost of it because we want to
union the cost and make sure we have all
the costs from different data sets in
the same table and in here in this
fields node so if you use that one you
can
for example just choose the index and
then the cost
and if you look at the output
every time you do something it will also
generate the output you can see
the add in there and the cost that's
associated with it so basically at every
step of the transformation that you take
you get to basically view what you're
doing already similarly how you preview
a query and for example for the google
ads data if somebody has worked with
this kind of data before
one part that is usually tricky there is
you have to divide it by a million
because the cost is multiplied
so it's per million and then we for
example have the functions node which is
a low code version for people who use
google sheets a lot of business users
you can just pull that functions node in
and there we have basically all kinds of
transformations that you would know both
from like python for example or even in
google sheets as formulas and in here
for example you can then create a new
column that's called spend where you
divide
the cost by a million so you can go
ahead and do that as well if you want to
um and then you will see
that the data is manipulated and a new
column is created that's called spend
where everything is divided by a million
so
in this case most of them have zero but
if you for example have it here
you'll get to see the spend
um
yeah and yeah
yeah it's in in sql agree a select state
a statement yeah so they could select
the certain columns that you have and
that functions is where you do your
manipulation of the data essentially
the other part will be so here for
example we now have the google data
we would maybe also want to pull in the
facebook data
so once you pull that in we will do the
same thing just select a couple of
fields
in here so you could do index again and
then in this case
you have um
other parts which is called spend in
facebook and again if you click on on
output you get to see
the same thing that you did for google
in this case it's actually the same so
one thing that i will forgot to put in
here is the date because we want to make
sure for example to see the um
the spend that we have for each time
period so in this case for example you
could pull in the day
column as well and you see here it's a
text format and then we could use the
parser as well in this case it's for
and here in the facebook one i would do
the same as well
i believe it's state start
and you can see it's in here as well you
have it in a different format for
example
and the idea is you can do any kind of
transformation you want with these drag
and drop nodes so you could for example
in here if you follow along just use the
date parser to parse a text field how
you would do it in sql by getting to
date functions or in bigquery you can
use those as well you would select your
source column your target column and
then basically just define the format so
you can look at your input to just get
an understanding of your data
and then you basically just write out
the the coverage so in this case it's
day day month month year year
and if you now
wait for the output a bit it will
process that and actually create a date
field that you can then reuse in your
visualizations
so now you can see here it's a date
field
and everything gets transformed into
a date format as well
this will take a couple of seconds just
because we have a bunch of rows in here
for the precalculation
and you'll see now here it's it's
transformed into a different format and
we could do the same thing again in in
the facebook one so here we could add a
date parser to it um transform the date
functions here and the functions you can
even generate constants so you could
have
for example
this one
loading it quite a bit slow you can you
can create other basically columns where
you just say this for example the google
one just for the sake of the time
because it took a bit longer here i'll
show you what a finished model would
look like
um once this is loading
so here for example everything starts
with like just having the google ads
selecting the fields so this case it's
cost spend and day
you parse the date you have text
extraction nodes you have functions that
you can use um
and in the end here this is what i meant
before where you for example want to tag
a certain column as google
and the last part where it's like
usually just the union you can union
both data sets to have
both the facebook and your google data
in one place
and that was the idea that for example
raycon had right and for them it was
quite a lot like they had to write
python scripts they had to make sure
that everything works attached with each
other and in here it literally took them
three to five minutes just pulling
everything in
learning a bit more and then just
outputting it
and what you can see here is it's all
version controlled as well
so if you look at the the rollback model
we save basically all the models that
you have so if multiple people are
working on it somebody's taking over at
some point they get to see the version
that you have you can come at a
different one
and you would see the differences as
well
so
in this case if anybody's still doing it
i can change this to
fb instead of facebook once this is
loading in
save this one and then go back to the
output
save this one then you can see i can
commit my change because something has
changed now so i would give it a title
as like changing
facebook to fb
and once i commit that it will
basically simmer to github in there just
create a new one that is in there and
you can always roll back from that one
as well
here you can now see that i changed it
to facebook and if you want to go back
to this one
it would go back to having facebook in
there as you can see here and then you
would commit it again and then it would
actually change the underlying data
structure
the next part of that i mean if you have
any questions about that part i mean
it's it's quite a lot to to just intake
right now but we made it basically for
business users to understand
quite easily but yeah there's the next
part is then the visualization where
it's essentially what you already know
it's drag and drop super simple for for
users to use in this case it's already
an existing model
if you go in there you can add a widget
um choose the data set that you have so
in this case it's a demo model
and then just drag and drop your data in
there to create the visualizations that
you want to have
for example you want to see the date
at a spent
by date broken down by the platform
so it's this way around
um i actually think
oh
yeah it's this way sorry segment of
um segment by spend and then uh
segment by date and summarize by
spending you would see for example the
year of the day will be
64k in facebook and then 14k in
google if we do the other way around and
just want to look it by month then you
can do that as well so it's it's that
part you can have as well
um but yeah so this essentially is is
the first part of the platform where
you have all this you can orchestrate
this you can you can set up your direct
a-secret graphs and all that but i
actually would want to go over now to
the second part which is actually using
github as as the engine behind it
and this one will take over
in just a second
do you wanna
take it now
all right thank you so much for
um yeah taking a look at the previous
version that we had so
um but here and just showed you yeah the
platform that
we
were running for the past two years um
and the new platform that gets published
now within the next six weeks uh i'm
gonna quickly show it to you guys you
know like what's really happening in
case you haven't been uh to my talk
what is happening now is uh in a you
know very brief
to to showcase you guys
we run an all-in-one data workspace
and um
so we have an integration tool sorry
yeah to sum it up again
what you saw
is
we
tried to cover the entire data pipeline
and make it very usable for business
users so we integrate with a lot of
different tools as you saw in the
platform we
have a ui modeling layer that barteen
just walked you over you could use a
native sql
model as well to transform your data you
can visualize it you can send the data
back to other tools where you need it
and you have an orchestrator that's
similar like airflow running on top of
it and you have like the data lineage
and cataloging which you know you can
explore within the app a bit as well um
so all in all um that's you know the old
version that you have access to right
now and it has a lot of different
problems right like for example if you
want to template stuff um under the hood
we run my sql databases for each of
these tools so it's very hard to like
roll back the rollback that you just saw
there was kind of
saving different versions within mysql
and it's not very natively
integrated and also templating was super
difficult like if you work on the same
model right now as batian you would keep
overwriting him or he would override you
and so a lot of you know different
problems come with this approach
that we have and this is why we decide
to hey let's completely scratch all of
my sql data databases uh and really run
git uh under the hood and i know there
are a lot of people in here that
probably haven't used git that that much
basically it's a version control system
git is the reason why the open source
community exists or at least version
control before git there was something
else right and
it basically lets you collaborate and
work async with super powers and
this is the reason why we're advancing
so much right now in the software
industry because of git of version
control and we want to take all of this
power um to our new platform and make it
you know get as a nosql data place uh
make it a very native uh
integration um yeah native part of our
app and running also git under the hood
means we are able now with the new
version to extend to any tools
of the modern data stack so for example
integrations you already see
we have airbyte running
alongside of our integrations now five
tran now you in the orchestrator we can
trigger now an airflow run and the
airflow run will get notified when you
know our orchestrator finishes and vice
versa airflow can trigger us um and also
we continue to have our ui model because
that's very inclusive for the business
user to work well with the technical
users
then you have also sql model that also
yeah you can write ginger now using dbt
instead of
yeah so you can run dbt alongside with
us
visualizations you know you we create
tables in the data warehouse you can
literally just plug and play with all
the tables using lookup tableau or our
own visualization uh we can you know
send the data back uh to like sensors uh
like trigger sensors
or trigger high touch or whatever
within a part of the platform
and now
what that allows us and i'm going to
quickly showcase you really the power of
the platform now
live so i'm already inside this data
council space and this space here um
it's already set up it's connected to a
repo called white y42 underscore data
counts and minus db
and yeah it's basically
so it's connected to a git repo and what
we do with our new app is we build our
own git engine
within the browser using web assembly so
what it does when we refresh the app you
will see that
what's happening under the hood and
maybe i'm going to open the console
we run a bus and get under the hood and
we cloning
the repo the remote repository we are
checking out right now the current
branch is the master branch we uh
basically use the file system of the app
under the hood and you can see it in the
index db here
um that's the yeah basically
all the git repo this one for the uh y42
minus data council um yeah in case you
know like that's a structure you know a
lot of binaries uh here of git that that
runs and so now the power of this is
really
whatever you do within the ui it gets
committed to this repo and i already
cloned this repo
that's not
it let me open i cloned this repo
already
within my
within my local machine i'm going to
open it up
as a new window
so
this is basically
what you see
and we're saving every data now within
this repo and the interest now let's uh
just you know uh we are now on the
master branch okay um and i'm gonna
create a new integration and i'm gonna
use the google ads integration uh we use
uh and call it yo
yo yo so it's very recognizable um and
what really happens here is i'm actually
committing right now um the changes and
we can check out the history so i just
come like i just created this
integration and it's called yoyo and i
committed these changes uh and two files
called metadata and settings uh.json you
will you know understand it if you use
our platform a bit more so let me go to
the
here
this is github desktop and i'm now going
back to the master branch i'm going to
fetch
and i'm going to see hey i just
committed these two files right here so
i have this also now on my local machine
as you can see
and this is the this yoyoyo thing that
you just saw uh now i have it within the
repo within my git database so to say
right and what we can do now is it's an
interplay between the uh the y42 bob
that also commits to that data so i'm
going to authorize myself now and when i
do
what's happening is
we authorize ourselves we send that
token that we just you know generated
from
accessing like giving access to
google ads
and the back end the y42 bot basically
takes it
and commits uh a secret uh like an
encrypted version so we can see it now
in the history
um we just uh committed a secret and
this is the y42 bot that commits to that
um
yeah repo now let's take a look we don't
have it here yet right now i'm gonna uh
go here and i'm gonna pull the changes
and we can see immediately hey the y42
bot just committed this one secret uh
now we see in here also everything that
is dot y42 is the folder that our
backend basically commits to and now
you're going to see in the next step
hey
we just loaded now the accounts because
like now i'm going to select one account
and we can see also again what happens
is we're really using it as a mysql
database
because now the import starts
like
we just committed the back end the y422
bot committed all the accounts that we
have available for google ads to be able
to select
and yeah and then we can display that in
the ui and so let the user select hey i
just selected this google ads account
where i want to import data from
and
now i also again i selected that account
and i selected the date when i started
to you know like importing this data so
um as you can see it's an interplay
between the web app committing to this
one repo between our the y42 bot
committing to the same repo
now you see the y42 repo just committed
something again the schema just loaded
now and this uh like this is the schema
that could be dynamic right like for my
sql integration it could be different
tables it could be different columns
and all of that really
was yeah
completely
let me just quickly pull the changes
here again
and
i'm pulling the changes right here so
all of this you can see now accounts and
schema.json
was saved within the y42 folder and let
me just you know maybe import called
an account called ad groups let me
commit that
so
what i just did
was i committed the new file
and
we also ran a job now that takes the
settings so from when should i start
import the data when
you know what columns should we start
importing and all of that
is
streaming in here now
and you can see also
again going back to this folder
and pulling again what's happening under
the hood
pull the changes
you suddenly see hey
there's a new table that we created
called ad groups and there's a run which
is we take the request
which columns do i want to import
which table it is
and then it was created at this time and
right now it's still pending and let's
go back in here
it's still pending i assume that check
check out the locks
finish table okay it should be done any
second now
fetching changes
now it's done it's ready as you can see
here so it also means
that
yeah it becomes green right here uh
let's go back to pulling the changes
here
and
what happened is the import finish so it
changes from ready to from pending to
ready so it means we also commit all the
jobs now within you know uh this git
repo and the power of it is hey i'm have
this yoyoyo change right here so let me
you know go to another um like branch to
the
uh leave my now let me
what is that change oh
let me discard the change here
i'm switching to this branch now and
clearly this yoyoyo account is not here
right as you can see and
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
merge the main the master branch and we
see hey there's 11 commits for master
that would make merge to this branch and
i will just go ahead and do that
so you can see now
this yoyo account is right here
available
in this new branch
and what we could change is like hey i'm
i'm on the bachai branch as you can see
here i'm actually going to switch it
again go to this branch so i'm changing
my ide up here also um
i have to pull first
yeah now the yoyo
should show up somewhere there it is
um i'm just gonna change the naming of
it here called
wazap
and i will commit now this change
and i'm doing it all from the ui here so
you can follow along the file structure
and you see yoyoyo i'm just going to
fetch it again
and it posts automatically so
it becomes now what's up
at the same time and um yeah
i mean i can continue showing you the
whole platform right it's really uh
everything is code now so you can change
anything in your ide it's all protected
within your ide with json schema so
maybe i can quickly show it to you
within the visualization so i have a
dashboard right here
global says tracker tag like
cs
i added as a tag let me commit that
merge new tag
um you see i just added the tag sales in
here commit that change
um we'll
pull that change now
and i will go to the visualization to
the dashboards um i think it was global
sales tracker yeah this one and so you
will see the metadata json here
that has this text
and oh
we up something here
it should be the right json schema link
it would basically restrict me from you
know removing properties here uh that
are not allowed so there's some small
issues here but you get the idea and um
the powerful thing of all of this is we
have everything implemented you know
within the ui like i changed something
here you see i changed the name from
this to this and i have all the commands
um the power of a cli and of a yeah
basically of git let's just maybe check
out the git status so i added the
metadata here in wi-fi to my sql right
and like in my demo what i did was i
stashed these changes and it reacts like
the ui reacts to the commands that
you're building like
yeah that you generate here so you see
here i have one stash change i rename
from this uh to this and so i want to
discard this change because yeah i don't
want that
so it stays like this and with that we
can we also have our own cli for example
uh you can see here the y42
help you can generate news
new integrations for example
and general integrations
let's check what we need so
we have a couple of options here
integration
name description okay all right then let
me do a
name
some new integration
of
description
of type mysql
and
oh
what did i do wrong
integration
nice
yeah so i just created now basically a
new mysql just using um the cli
and you can
automate
everything that you see with our apis as
well so
maybe let's quickly do that um
let's go back to
this wassup that we kind of like
so um for that
i'm just going to quickly take the the
token out of here so we can trigger the
api
so i wanna trigger let's say a new
import
um
i put in the right token
um let's see when what branch are we now
we are on the bachai branch okay
i know it's company141
this is
okay now i want to execute one command
uh now i need to find the location
of this integration
which let's check out the path in here
it's the wassup
uh oh uh
on the right yeah
here it's this one
so let's go the creation
and it's the ad groups
that i want to execute
doesn't look like it works
what's the
problem
all right oh this is the one
put in the wrong repo
now i'm going to execute that
now it works true
and i'm just going back here i'm not
doing anything it's fetching the changes
and basically i'm triggering
the api automatically to run another job
but it's not just about running the jobs
it's running
everything programmatically within the
y42 platform you can authorize yourself
with integrations you can trigger jobs
you can set up new orchestration set up
new visualizations so the entire
platform is fully
enabled everything is code you can use
the cli you can use the
yeah the ui to create it you can use the
command line interface the api
and
you can really
run your entire data pipeline
programmatically
code it use a ui for it all in one
extended what by whatever tool you need
it to be and we really think that by the
end of this year we will probably change
the entire data industry significantly
with this approach
so
yeah you're very welcome to check out
the new version in six weeks from now
thank you
[Applause]